hello and welcome to this video playing
Frank ed so let's see what happens here
in this game going for a few kilo and is
playing this time playing the hippo and
we'll see that so clock made of mine by
the way yeah well the hippo is not the
greatest opening ever but against the
relatively tame setup like this you can
definitely play it yeah let's see if I
can do something you open up the
position sometimes you can get funny
structural chat transpositions here for
example some kind of rule or pass might
might actually happen like after if I
have a g5 this could easily be a room
okay it takes this doesn't look very
threatening looks like a good a good
room so this one or King f7 way I have
to have to look a little bit in its not
be too quick
okay i'm starting with this move this is
part of the part of the plants here
anyway so now King age seven after new
gate i can go brigade yet Bishop takes
f7 if I would have delayed this C formal
so ya ever move the night Queen d6s
possibly coming I think I'm going to
take the heavy pieces of the board for
the moment and hear how to do this mmm i
would like nights of five but okay seven
is a bit of a bit of an issue there
hmm
look a8 not sure about that trade down
yeah the trade a minister group d 1 this
is stronger than the trade on a 8th
route d 1 95 and 96 this is one of
absolutely I'm not sure about that could
be a problem actually maybe I should
move the night somewhere else in c 5
because c5 is also an unprotected square
this one maybe this one 26 i can just
take yeah which is also it's not that
easy i actually had a completely wrong
idea there
it's very comfortable that Queen d6 move
all the time
Knight to c8 it's not to move that I
love to play but let's do it covered is
six it takes this time they're each for
okay
this is supposed to go to e6 494
potentially
yeah so this pollen see form looks weak
now this is a move that I had a head on
the radar but I wasn't sure I'm really
if I can do something about it making
all 96 actually this is uh yeah why not
okay no I'm going to jump in yes
okay he's got he's got Bishop be one in
that case I can't play we should be five
I mean just covering this I'm still I'm
still behind timewise surprisingly
now that ending should be okay i always
have not be five for example to attack a
c3 and so on let's see night here is
good night be one it's not very active
but definitely a possibility ok so back
but this not so easy to play for white
anyway an i don't f4 is immensely
annoying
time warning didn't have enough time now
to figure this out but this looks okay I
cannot take on d3 after my day 3 Bishop
a three
I don't really I'm taking this one then
I was I was very helpful yeah and
winning the game was difficult only
possible with the blunder like that
White Rose I yeah it's a bit surprising
that i actually won this game I thought
that around here I should be okay but
that weakness on the 6th is still quite
an issue so this this it felt kind of
normal maybe around here there is way
for improvement on a computer actually
things I'm okay him I had some some
doubts check hear the engine gives why
the clear advantage check with this move
this is very strong okay yeah it is very
strong I mean it looks just from the
pure first impression it looks it looks
annoying but the issue is that there's
just age six is hanging and I cannot
take it quite letting this would be
disastrous with this and this coming
check now it takes takes takes takes and
again night f5 is is killing but not at
five again this is the thing he only has
yes this opportunity this one
opportunity and now think so I ok the
engine gives this move I didn't really I
know I can yeah well I saw this this is
the thing i saw this but i didn't this
is what it wants to play ok the idea
being this poo now that's a tough tough
tough continuation to go for your blog
is ok ok i didn't see this and thought
this ending is equal
yeah and here he blended the bishop I
mean he has to take him and continue
this position I think probably here and
there is no particular promising way
forward is not only three looks active
but it's not connected to the rest of my
my pieces so there is no clear way what
to do it's probably equal engine also
gives 0 0 0 and this is a piece well
those things can happen ok I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching